[Music]
here we
go God I love this
[Music]
book see I sing the truth who's the
weirdo
now not a real F don't worry I have it
all under control
I got everything under
[Music]
control are you okay told you that we
were
coming who
you don't answer you're going to be the
same temperature as my coffee right now
which thanks to you is ice cold
[Music]
fine you and I we're not so different
you're a terrorist then what agent ARA
does that make you had to bring the cat
what did you expect me to do leave him
defend for himself come on be fine cat
ladies always die alone the cats figure
it out I am not a cat lady I'm
not and what's your problem with my cat
exactly he's really cute he's cuddly
he's loyal kind you suddenly Dro dead
that cat's chewing your ears off within
48 hours max which with you around gets
more likely by the
minute aryle is it's pretty crazy
mindblowing smart
sexy
it's called reality but it's Matthew
vaugh so it's a heightened reality you
can't always understand The Madness of
Matthew vaugh you just have to go with
it it's an interesting mix of reality
and fantasy to reinvent everything you
think you know about spy movies the
greater the Spy the bigger the
LIE there's always a surprise there's
always lots of excitement it's wild
anything can happen trust me definitely
unexpected going to be slightly mad
watch this and it's not stop wherever
you think this movie is going I love
this book you are wrong it's time for
you to meet the real agent Argy oh my
God oh my God oh my
God agent
[Music]
Argy I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
out
put on
your you and I we're not so different
agent are
go it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother ell it's called a
copout
whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book
come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked a
hornets nest you didn't even know
existed I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Ary oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
God